yeah
[Music]
great welcome back everyone it's great
to have
David David is one of the longterm
participants and also one of the main
organizers of the previous Workshop
so's agreed
to okay yeah thanks for inviting me and
uh thanks for coming so the title of the
talk is tight bounds for active LP
regression and Beyond this is based on
two different Works uh the first is
joint with Cameron musco who's here
Chris musco and my student
Tuda and the second uh is a followup uh
with Tuda so yeah let me tell you about
the active learning setting that we
consider so here is a standard problem
in active learning an example so here is
a um a chest CT scan of um of a patient
say think of this as a data point and
you want to know does this patient have
covid or not so you go to a doctor and
the doctor looks at this example and
says that lung definitely has covid um
and then he
says that will be $50 okay so you know
this is uh a label that we're assigning
to this example which is expensive okay
and in
general uh the idea behind Active
Learning is that often times the largest
bottleneck in machine learning
applications is the collection of labels
okay they don't need to be uh
necessarily costly it could be that you
know you need to feed an input through a
very complicated model just to get the
corresponding
label and so Active Learning aims to
minimize the number of label entries
that are
read okay
and the most basic question in active
learning or one of the most basic is
active linear regression which is what
we're going to focus on in this
talk okay so here's the problem setting
this is the standard uh Vector uh P
Norm what are we given we're given a
design Matrix a which is n by D think of
the rows as being n
examples uh they each have d features
which is also the number of variables
that will be in the regression
problem we'll consider the over
constraint case so we're thinking of
many more examples and then features
D and our access to the label Vector B
is through query axis okay we want to
minimize the number of queries to this
Vector
B and what do we want to Output we want
to Output a coefficient Vector X Prime
in R to the D and we're looking for a
relative error solution here so the P
Norm of ax Prime minus B the regression
cost is at most 1 plus Epsilon time the
optimal regression
cost okay and as I said we want to
minimize the number of entries in B that
we
read okay so what is known about active
LP
regression using classical techniques in
randomized linear algebra
it's not hard to get for least squares
regression P equals 2 it's not hard to
get a bound of uh D log
D plus d over
Epsilon um you can show that just
sampling according to the leverage
scores of a matrix uh gives this bound
so the leverage scores of the a matrix
doesn't involve B at
all and um so that's that's what you can
get with standard Tech a result of
tenant price was able to get rid of this
log D Factor so they get a tight query
complexity bound of D over Epsilon okay
and their proof uses uh BSS like
techniques it's a randomized algorithm
of course as all algorithms need to be
in the active
setting
um then uh came a work of Chen and
dzinski and independently of perar perar
and price which studied uh P equals 1
now unlike P equals 2 which has a lot of
algebraic structure you can kind of take
the objective function use Pythagorean
theorem to decompose it into a part only
depending on a and a part that is a DOT
product for which you can uh sample from
a and approximate the dotproduct with B
has nice algebraic structure P equals 1
you know has less algebraic structure
but it still has nice structure okay so
um using specific properties of P equals
one
those authors were able to show a tight
bound of D over Epsilon squar up to log
factors okay um and they kind of you
know they use a really nice form of
looking at the difference of uh they
look at quantities of the form ax minus
B1 minus ax star minus
B1 and you know this can be upper
bounded in terms of just the norm of ax
minus ax star the one Norm um so when P
equals one there's a very nice way of
controlling this quantity um and so they
were only able to get a result for p
equals one that's kind of what I'm
trying to say
um they
did do some kind of tailor expansion On
a related quantity to get some bounds
for p between one and two they were able
to get a worse D squ over Epsilon squar
bound um and one of their open questions
was you know can you get linear in D and
what is the optimal Epsilon dependence
for p in this
range so this is the state-of-the-art uh
before our work for LP regression active
LP
regression okay so in our uh work with
musco musco and Thai uh what we first
were able to show is that for p between
one and two that you can uh actually get
a d over Epsilon bound okay so you can
improve this d^ s to D and you can
improve this Epsilon squ to Epsilon and
that's also
tight
okay um for p greater than
two uh in our initial paper we had a
bound you we had the first non-trivial
bound for this range of P we had a bound
um which was uh D to the p over 2 over
Epsilon to the P this was an upper
bound and we had a lower bound of uh D
the p over 2 plus 1 over Epsilon to the
P minus one so this is what we had in
the in the first paper and in the
follow-up paper we were able to get a a
tight bound which is D to the p over2
over Epsilon to the P minus
one
okay um and I'm not going to talk much
about it but uh you know when p is less
than one it's not a norm but you it's
you know you can still think of the lp
Norm as a well- defined quantity and you
can get tight bounds of D over Epsilon
squar in that case we show
that okay
so active LP
regression um sorry David quick
question oh the the so is p also one
over sorry P equals one also one over or
is it one this is uh very interesting so
when p is one uh these papers show that
D Epsilon squ is tight they provide a
lower bound and once p is slightly
larger than one I mean so we're assuming
here p is a is a constant between one
and two then the bound becomes D over
Epsilon because there's a phase
transition at P equals one okay so if
you sort of parameterized it there would
be some funky oh function of p uh is
that as itach like say if p was a
function of D then there would be some
weird extra dependence somewhere like as
P gets very close to one yeah as P gets
very close to one yeah exactly yeah yeah
I'm assuming here that P is a constant
bounded away from from
one any other
questions
okay okay so um I just mentioned the
results for LP losses I'm just repeating
them here I've drawn the these squares
loss and the L1 loss these were the
bounds that I said in the paper we also
get bounds for uh a large number of
other loss functions um of M estimator
losses and in particular we look at one
of the losses is is the Huber loss so
the Huber loss is quadratic near the
origin and at some point it shifts to
becoming linear this is useful um it
enjoys uh smoothness properties near the
origin and robustness properties is uh
away from the origin like L1 loss um
also enjoys but L1 loss is not smooth
and for hubber loss we get kind of a
weird looking bound of roughly D to the
1.72 over poly
Epsilon uh we also consider tukos
another popular m estimator which is
quadratic near the origin and at some
point it just becomes completely
flat okay and uh for this we get D squ
over poly on and I'm hiding log factors
um and we handle many other M
estimators uh we're not getting tight
bounds in terms of d uh there's also
there's some very recent work of Aon
young um Ain and um James Lee that gets
uh I believe Subspace embeddings for
Huber loss and Tuki loss I don't know if
they apply to the active setting so yeah
probably probably okay yeah um okay so
that's that that would be great if if
that works then you for the active
setting you know the hope is that you
can get D over poly
Epsilon um okay
so yeah I just want to motivate you know
one more simple application of uh active
regression which is chronic or product
regression this is a problem that is
well studied in uh signal processing
communities and some other places
where uh the design Matrix is only given
to you in implicitly okay so the design
Matrix is actually a chronical product
of two matrices A1 through A2 that
you're
given um so here think of each AI is
being n by d n much larger than
D and so you know this actual Matrix
this chronical product is n to the Q by
D to the
Q and maybe D to the Q is tolerable
maybe D is not so large um but maybe n
to the Q is is way too large to to do
anything with
and you'd like to solve this problem so
you know and maybe you're not you know
you're you're not in the active setting
you you you could have you could read B
uh it's not expensive to read B but B is
an end to the Q dimensional Vector so it
take a lot of time to read all of
it um yeah so as I said this is used in
Signal processing it's also used in
spline
regression and there's previous work on
this problem uh the the best previous
work obtained one plus Epsilon
approximation in the number of non-zero
entries of the AI the sum of that over I
but it had a plus n andz of B term okay
and as I just said that's really bad
right because n andz of B can be as
large as uh n to the Q if if you have a
dense label Vector um so the hope is
that you could remove it and using these
active regression techniques
uh for every P we can remove this n andz
of B term and get real input sparsity
time algorithm for chronic or product
regression okay a simple
application any
questions okay so let me give a proof
sketch of the uh bounds for LP
regression and if time permits talk a
little bit about M
estimators so here's the plan for the
proof in the first part I'm going to
discuss sensitivity sampling and and uh
more refined Notions of that called
chaining and a key idea that we use
which is partitioning the label vector
by
sensitivities this first part will allow
us to obtain optimal dependencies on D
for LP regression for every
p and then I'll talk about the second
part which is I'm call which I'm calling
iterating with near Optimal Solutions
I'll describe what that means but this
will allow us to get optimal
dependencies on Epsilon as
well
okay so here's the highlevel algorithmic
approach the idea is to try to select
some important training examples just
rows of the design Matrix
a and read the corresponding labels of
the label Vector
B and possibly or usually you want to
reweight what you've read and solve the
smaller problem okay this is you know
the algorithm that we would like to
work um so we'd like to design some
distribution to choose important
examples what does important mean
here okay so that's sort of a sample and
solve
approach and so let stimes a be the uh
sample and reweighted Matrix and S times
B the same for the label
vector
well sensitivity sampling gives you a a
natural way of choosing important
training
examples okay so what is that well
what's one property we would
like we would like that s * a this small
subset of uh reweighted rows of a we'd
like it to approximate
a in the sense that for all vectors that
a acts on for all X we have that the PM
of SX is within 1 plus or minus Epsilon
of the PM of
ax okay so how should we sample rows of
a with no particular X in mind we'd like
this to hold for all
X well sampling each row proportional to
its sensitivity can get this what is the
sensitivity so the I sensitivity of a is
the supremum over X of the I row of a do
X absolute value to the p over the P
Norm of ax to the P okay so it's the
supremum as I range over all vectors ax
in the column span of a of the fraction
of the PM that's in the I uh entry or
fraction of PM to the p in the I
entry okay so that's the I
sensitivity um what's important is the
ratio of these two
quantities
and the sensitivity score as I said
captures the largest fraction of LP Norm
by the I coordinate as you range over
the
Subspace there are nice properties about
sensitivities so the sum of the
sensitivities is not too large in the
sense that it doesn't depend on N so if
p is less than or equal to two the sum
is at most
D and for p larger than two it's at most
D the p over
okay
um yeah if you haven't seen this before
when P equals 2 the sensitivities are
actually the squared row Norms of an
orthonormal basis for the column span of
a and the sum of the squared row Norms
is the same as the sum of squared column
norms and that's why it's equal to D in
that case right the sum of squared row
Norms of an orthonormal basis is D um so
that's that's sort of the proof for p
equals
2 and this is the generalization to
arbitrary p
so I just like to stress here that what
this sum says is that not too many rows
can be too important okay it's
small now one problem with sensitivity
sampling in the active setting is that
this label VOR B is not a column of
a and sensitivities of a do not
necessarily capture large entries of B
there could be some very large entry of
B that's you know attached to a row of a
that has very small
sensitivity sorry David yeah I'm gonna
ask another question yeah uh when you
said that your results for p greater
than two are are tight yeah uh this is
related to like this quantity is also
tight or something the one you just
showed this uh the large leverage score
I'm actually going to I'll actually give
you a lower Bound for active regression
for yeah so the the tight bound was
Theta D the p over2 over Epsilon the P
minus one and you can show uh a hard
instance where if you don't read this
number of entries in the B Vector then
you can't get a one plus Epsilon
approximation I mean it is related to
that uh because you know I ultimately
there's an algorithm that uses facts
like this to achieve this but the proof
is just a direct hard instance yeah
yeah um any other questions
okay um yeah so the point here is that
you know B is not a column of a so the
distribution that you're looking at
doesn't capture large entries of
b um so what you know what what can we
at least get very easily well we can
start by getting a constant Factor
solution without looking at B at all um
so if we sample here's how you do it if
you sample each row of a with
probability equal to its sensitivity
then what you can show is that for a
fixed Vector
X the PM of sax is within a constant
factor of the P of ax with constant
probability okay this is just an
expectation a second moment method
argument
okay
um and what is the expected number of
samples that you take well if you're for
each row if you're including it with
probabbly proportional to its
sensitivity then the expected number of
samples is the sum of the sensitivities
which we said is fairly
small okay so this was for a fixed X how
do we get a statement for all
X well the uh you can show that the
dependence on the failure probability
will be log one over Delta so you'll get
log one over Delta times the sum of
sensitivities
bound and if you just do a standard net
argument you choose an exponential and D
siiz net then you can Union bound uh
over all net vectors um so burnstein's
inequality plus this net argument will
give you D to the max of 1 and P over2
plus one rows and now you can say the
statement that for all X simultaneously
the P Norm of sax is within a constant
factor of
ax okay why is this useful for active
regression um well let's just say that
we do this sensitivity sampling with
with this number of
rows and we get our Matrix uh sa and
corresponding label Vector part of the
label Vector that we read
SB and we do this sample and solve
approach so we solve this small problem
and we get our constant Factor solution
let's call that X
subc why is this a good solution well
it's a very simple argument based on
triangle inequality if I look at the
cost of using this solution
XC then the lp regression cost is by
triangle inequality at most the lp
regression cost of axar minus B where
xar is the optimal pnorm uh
solution uh to the regression problem
plus the P Norm of axar minus uh
axc that's this triangle
inequality the next inequality this
Optimum axar minus b p is this the same
and all we did is we said that this
quantity here is at most s times that
quantity right because s is a constant
factor of Subspace embedding yeah so for
I've never used Norms between zero and
one they're not Norms but this doesn't
hold for between yeah you can have you
can get an approximate triangle in
equality you lose something there yeah
yeah any other
questions okay um so yeah so so we need
s you know to not uh shrink the norm of
any vector and that's what this property
says um what do we know about this PM
well we can again apply a triangle
inequality and say that the PM of saxar
minus sax
C is order
um uh yeah is the PM of saxar minus SB
plus the P of SX C minus SB right let's
just triangle inequality again um I just
put a b for both of
these finally what do we know about this
sum well XC is the optimal solution to
the sampled problem
right so that means that this
PM is at most this PM right where xar is
the optimal solution to the original
problem
yeah okay so we just need to understand
what is the PM of saxar minus SB and the
sampling Matrix S uh gives you an
unbiased uh estimator for any fixed
Vector uh
xstar that doesn't depend on it just
some fixed Vector X star and so it's a
non- negative random variable just by
markup inequality uh this is at most a
constant Factor times the P Norm of axar
minus B that's order opt okay so this is
a very simple way to get a constant
Factor solution to active
regression um just by sensitivity
sampling
okay um the number of rows you get by
doing this is not tight uh you can get
rid of this plus one using more
sophisticated uh arguments but I just
wanted to give you an initial I'll talk
about those a little bit later initial
bound okay so how can we get a one plus
Epsilon approximation
though okay so let me first mention some
simplifications so we can first get in
order one approximation x sub c as as we
just uh described and we can
conceptually or even algorithmically
replace B with B minus a * x c okay you
know we don't actually have to do the
subtraction but every time we read an
entry of B we could replace it with this
you don't have to do this um I mean in
the analysis you should think of B being
replaced with B minus
axc
um why is this useful well
now you see that the um the norm of B is
uh of the new B is order
opt okay which means by triangle
inequality you only need to consider
those X for which the PM of ax is order
the norm of B there's no reason to
consider larger X because uh by triangle
in equality they'd have a cost that's
larger than order Norm of B which is
order
op okay and by linearity let's just
assume that the optimal cost is one uh
for the for the talk and so the yeah
just to summarize the P of ax is order
the p b which is order
one okay so let me describe now the main
idea uh for getting this optimal
dependence on
d u the main idea is that labels in the
B Vector that are too large are not
important okay if I have some very large
entry in b
and it's attached to some very small
sensitivity in a then if I really try to
fit that entry in
B then you know since the sensitivity is
so small I have to set the norm of ax to
be very large if the norm of ax is very
large you know relative to opt then it
means that you know I'm already not
getting a constant Factor solution much
less a 1 plus Epsilon approximation so
the idea is I can't actually fit entries
of B that are very large
okay so labels that are too large are
not
important um so let me just draw the
picture here um okay so again you know
from the last slide we said that the P
Norm of ax we're going to assume is
order
one um so that means that if I look at
the I coordinate the largest that AI dox
to the P could ever be is the
sensitivity Sigma I right it can't be
larger than that if the P of ax is order
one
okay well now let's look at coordinates
of
B so if I look at a coordinate of B
there sort of two cases one is it's not
too large and by too large I mean it's
not larger than Sigma I over Epsilon to
the P this turns out to be the the right
threshold to look
at so if it's not too large then you can
think of bi as being comparable to the I
sensitivity and so then when you try to
go through the
analysis um using uh ax minus B uh the
sensitivity analysis or more
sophisticated chaining
analysis then you can kind of you know
it doesn't change that much because the
coordinates these kind of these
coordinates of B are very comparable to
the sensitivities they don't change the
sensitivities of
a so that's the good
case and the Bad Case is when you have
some coordinates that are very
large okay and you know this can
certainly happen you know some
coordinates could be infinite you'll
never read them you don't know about
them um you know or you could with some
probability read them but you're not
going to try to fit them that's the
point okay
so if if I have a very large coordinate
bi uh very large bi then ax minus B the
I coordinate is dominated by bi for
every x that you care about for every X
such that the Pome of ax is order one
okay and what that effectively means is
these are not going to affect the cost
and they can be ignored okay you need to
formally show this and I'll say a little
bit more about that but um that's that's
the the high level strategy of the
proof so yeah let me describe where we
are
so sensitivity sampling selects
important rows of a and the problem was
that this preserves the lpor objective
for ax but not for ax minus
B and this idea of
partitioning coordinates of B by
sensitivity it effectively allows us to
ignore large entries of B okay so if bi
is much larger than Sigma I I'm dropping
Epsilon
factors then it cannot affect NE Optimal
Solutions okay you can show that both uh
after sampling and in the original uh uh
for the original regression problem
um and so for the purposes of analysis
we can actually zero out such bi
obtaining a vector B Prime where all the
entries in B Prime uh they're either
zero or they're at most this place where
we cap the entries this uh
um sensitivity divided by Epsilon to the
p and you can show that the sensitivity
sampling argument on B Prime goes
through okay so that's the rough idea um
one issue with this is It's using
sensitivity sampling so it's already not
going to get optimal bounds uh it ends
up getting D to the P over2 plus 1
instead of D to the P over2 um but it
actually you know it does go
through um to get better bounds we use
chaining arguments with Lewis weights
um so uh using chaining arguments goes
back to borain lenen R milman and Leu
tand simplified their
proof um using such arguments we're able
to improve the bounds uh to D to the max
of one over one and P over two so it's
optimal dependence on D and some
dependence on Epsilon which is
suboptimal um what are Lewis weights if
you haven't seen
them so the lp Lewis weights which I've
written as uh w1p w2p
wnp they satisfy a very nice uh equation
uh defined in terms of themselves which
is that the the I leis weight is the uh
L2 sensitivity which is just the
leverage score I didn't Define leverage
score but it's the L2 sensitivity of um
W to the 12 minus 1 over P * a where W
is a diagonal matrix which has the uh
leis weights the lp leis weights on the
diagonal okay so a prior it's not even
clear that such leis weights exist but
they do they can be found efficiently um
there are algorithms of Cohen Pang and
others that find these very quickly find
good estimates of
these um and you can yeah compute these
to high accuracy and and so on so
there's a lot of study on leis weights
they can be found quickly um and they
related to sensitivities there are nice
relationships so the uh uh the ice
sensitivity I'm writing it here as SI
but the you know it's still the same
sensitivity that we had before the ice
sensitivity with respect to the pnorm is
that most
D to the max P 2us 1 and Z time the I
leis weight okay so when p is uh less
than two the Lewis weights uper bound
the sensitivities otherwise there's some
polyd
loss um now yeah how do we use this in
the active setting uh we initially had a
proof uh that went through borgan Lin
Ros mman it was very messy um but
there's a much simpler proof due to L
and telegran which we end up using we
end up using that because it changes
very minimally in the active setting
okay when you have this Vector B
Prime um oh
sorry yeah so let me just say what the
the algorithm that we analyze ends up
being which is the algorithm uh uh well
it's existential in the D telr but this
is the sort of the algorithm from there
um so here's algorith one which I'm
calling LP
sampling uh we have the Matrix a as
input and we want to Output a diagonal
sampling Matrix
S how does it work well we first compute
approximate Lewis weights so this leis
weights W Tilda I are overestimates to
the actual leis weights and instead of
summing up to at most D they sum up to
something know it's slightly larger than
D C1 time
D then we take this matx a and we need
to flatten rows of a what does that mean
we're going to create a new Matrix a
prime by replacing each row in a with
some number of copies of it okay so for
the I row we replace it with K copies
where K is proportional to the leis
weight the I leis weight of a so it's
the leis weight of a divided by roughly
D over
n and for each copy we scale it by K to
the 1 P one k one over P if you do this
then the leis then the uh LP Norm uh is
preserved for any x a prime X PM is the
same as ax PM for any X and the nice
thing about doing this is that the the
leis weights of the new Matrix a prime
are all
flat okay and so what you do now well
now on a prime you independently sample
each row with probably a
half okay and for rows you sample you
scale back back up by 2 the 1 P this
will preserve the the P Norm in
expectation for a fixed X um if you set
the constants appropriately the number
of rows in a goes down by a constant
Factor okay you need to set this C2 to
be large enough this just influences the
overall uh error in the chaining
argument that you look at and it can be
accounted for by adjusting Epsilon in
other places okay so the number of rows
is going to go down by a constant factor
and so what is the recursive algorithm
for LP
regression uh so yeah the the idea is um
if if the number n is small compared to
the number of samples you want to make
then you just solve regression uh by
reading all the labels in the B
Vector otherwise n is large and you just
replace a with uh stimes a by calling
this algorithm and replace B with s time
B by calling this algorithm you don't
actually have to read the entries in in
B to do that okay and so you just keep
recursing until you get down to the
number of rows that you want which is
the number of samples you're going to
read okay so each time you're reducing
by a constant
Factor that's the algorithm that we
analyze um you're just stepping back for
a minute like why are
we you know looking at Lewis weights and
analyzing this
algorithm why not just use sensitivity
sampling I just wanted to give a little
bit of intuition about that um
if you're not familiar with with
chaining at all
so the naive sensitivity sampling
analysis as I said you do a Burn scene
argument uh and a net bound and it loses
a factor of D the sample complexity is
the total sensitivity times the net size
and the reason this is suboptimal is
because it assumes a worst case variance
okay so after you split the coordinates
and you have this Matrix a prime you can
show that all the coordinate Val values
are roughly within a factor of D that
you care about okay and sensitivity
sampling the analysis it assumes that
you're always going to get these
slightly larger coordinates these
coordinates that are a value D instead
of the flat coordinates and that's why
you lose a factor of D in the
analysis so instead what caning does is
it has multiple Nets and it trades this
High variance this factor of D for a
smaller net size okay so sort of the
high variance coordinat can be covered
I'll say what that means a little bit on
the next slide with smaller Nets and so
you know even though you pay higher
variance you know the union bound over
is over a smaller number of things and
overall you reduce the the the total
sample
complexity so this is called compact
rounding in the uh berain linen Ros
Millman paper and the goal is to
construct a net end of
vectors such that for any uh
x uh you know in the set you're trying
to uh appro o imate there's a net Vector
y um that approximates ax on every
coordinate up to a 1 plus Epsilon Factor
so you're trying to approximate this
coordinate wise a vector ax and you want
your net of vectors to be
small um and a key observation uh which
is called dual sudakov
mination is that the size of a covering
of the lp ball ax by L Infinity ball
balls you can imagine you know you're
trying to approximate this coordinate
wise so you're trying to cover it with L
Infinity
balls if you look at L Infinity balls of
radius
T the uh the size uh uh of the net that
you need is exponential in D over
t^2 okay I'm not going to prove this or
give any intuition but you know just the
point is you know when T is is large the
net size is smaller as you would expect
okay because you have larger L Infinity
balls that you can use to cover
uh vectors in your LP ball um and yeah
so the idea is to construct your net n
using multiple L Infinity Nets with radi
that are increasing in powers of one
plus Epsilon and this is sort of the
rough idea behind chaining applied in
the
setting um that's all I'll say about
that um you know here's a glimpse of the
analysis you know the Leo telegran
analysis that I was uh talking about so
the idea is to look at this quantity
Capital Lambda it's the supremum over uh
vectors X such that the P of ax is at
most one we said we could look at those
vectors because uh you know those are
the only vectors that can give you uh 1
plus Epsilon approximate
Solutions and what we want to look at is
the P to the P of a SX minus the PM to
the P of ax now we want this Supremo to
be small we want it to be um at most
Epsilon and this sampling
Matrix well it has this nice form that
either I don't include a row in which
case I have a zero on the diagonal entry
or I do include the row and I have a two
when I raise it to the P power right
because I'm sampling half and I'm
scaling back up to preserve the P Norm
so I can write the uh diagonal elements
of s as 1 plus Sigma I where Sigma I is
a romok or a random sign um so I either
if I don't include the row it's zero if
I include it it's
two um and so you know I just took this
difference and wrote it coordinate
wise and you know taking differences
coordinate wise I get the sum of Sigma I
times um you know absolute value of axi
to the P that's the quantity that I want
to bound
um and uh you know so now I have this
you know if you've seen these you know
this is a nice uh ramaker uh process I
can I can try to bound this and there
are known bounds on this quantity so uh
the bound of Leu telegran says that the
expected value of this supremum
Lambda is you know something that looks
like what we want it's D to the max of
one and P over2 Over N times some log
factors the square root of that um and
so that's you know roughly what goes on
in chaining without in the in the
non-active setting in the standard
setting
um and you know by by the way this
expectation also comes with subian tail
bounds so verin has a nice uh uh
discussion of that uh you get you know
sub Galan concentration for this uh
supremum um what I wanted to say about
the active setting is things change a
little bit right because we have this B
Vector we said that we can replace it
with this Vector B Prime where the max
entries uh are Capp by the corresponding
sensitivities um more precisely by the
leis weights that are related to the
sensitivities in ways that I described
um and so you kind of just push through
the analysis with this extra uh B prime
vector and it works out I mean that's
the the short story of of how this
analysis Works
um yeah so so
so uh putting that all together does
give optimal balance in terms of D for
active regression for any
P
um
okay okay in the remaining amount of
time I wanted to talk about the Epsilon
dependence so a natural question is can
we do better those arguments I just
described don't get the optimal Epsilon
dependence
um well here's the idea which I was
calling iterating uh at the beginning of
the talk we can first obtain a one plus
root Epsilon approximation let's say
we're looking at P between 1 and two
okay so we know the optimal number of
queries is D over Epsilon that's what I
was claiming to
you um the previous analysis using
chaining would have a uh one over
Epsilon Square dependence instead of a
one over Epsilon
dependence but it's still useful for
getting an initial solution we can first
obtain a 1 plus root Epsilon
approximation with roughly D over
Epsilon queries using that
analysis okay then the key point is
that if I look at the lp squared loss
this is strongly convex with respect to
the lp Norm for p and one and P between
one and
two and so what ises that you know what
does that mean well what it means for us
is that if I have a solution X such that
the P Norm of ax minus B is at most 1
plus gamma
opt then in fact ax has to be close to
ax
star okay you can't have ax and ax star
being very far away and both having know
good
Solutions and in particular it means
that the Pome of axus ax star is order
root gamma times
opt okay um but then if ax and ax star
are close we can actually improve the
chaining arguments we can improve this
this framework that I was talking about
um we get an improved bound like now we
only have to look at vectors ax such
that ax you know that satisfy this the P
of axus ax star is order root gamma opt
okay this is better than what we were
looking at before like in the old
analysis I was saying we look at vectors
X for the P of ax is order one that was
order opt and now we get this sort of
you know smaller set that we have to
look at and because we have this smaller
set we can improve the chaining
arguments um and you know so if we
improve the taining arguments then it
actually means that you know uh with
that same number of samples you actually
got a better approximation than you
thought you
got and then you just keep iterating
this argument and you can iterate it
down all the way to D over Epsilon
queries so let me show that to you more
precisely on the next slide but before I
do let me just mention that um oh okay
yeah I can show you a picture of how
this works here so here is you know one
of the lp loss functions P between one
and
two and here is the optimum we're
minimizing and here's the optimum at the
origin and we got some some Vector X for
which the p minus B is at most 1 plus
gamma opt so that means that you know
the value is below this dotted
line okay but then by strong convexity
it means that okay well we only need to
consider uh you know it means ax is
close to ax
star so we only need to consider ax in
this range between these blue vertical
lines okay but then if we had ax minus
axr P Norm in this range it meant that
we would have a better sampling bound so
actually we would have had an even
better you know with the same number of
samples we would have had an even better
bound on the cost it would be below this
yellow line and then by strong convexity
that means that oh you know actually ax
is closer than to ax star than what we
thought and we just iterate this
argument and uh if you iterate it you
get down to you know you should you can
show that D over Epsilon queries
actually sufficed okay so this is there
might be a more direct way of proving
this this was our understanding of how
to prove it um I do want to mention
before I formally mention the recurrence
is that this is also how we obtain the
improvements for p greater than two okay
I mentioned that we had this follow-up
work that improved these bounds to this
bound um we don't have this uh strong
convexity but instead what we use is a
bregman Divergence of LP Norms uh by
people in this audience uh so uh uh Adil
uh rasmo um Richard Pang and
suant um and uh using that uh uh that
that bound that bragman Divergence what
we're able to show is that if the P Norm
of ax minus B is at most 1 plus gamma
opt here p is greater than two then
again ax is close to ax star in P Norm
like the difference is order gamma to
the one over P opt
okay so again it's this idea that you
know closeness in objective implies
closeness in the actual vectors um and
then therefore implies improved
chaining so you know what is roughly the
intuition of what's going on here um let
me just say something for p between one
and two so as I said you know we have
this simple Lemma from strong complexity
that if p is between one and two and the
objective is is a xus B is small then ax
and ax star are close this was what was
on the previous slide so think of a
think of a case where ax minus ax star
is a flat Vector okay all these
differences are you know roughly the
same
um now suppose I wanted to uniformly
sample
entries to approximate the
PM right so if I know uh um you know how
how many entries I need to approximate
the Pome of ax if I if I had ax star
well you if ax star were equal to ax I
wouldn't have to sample anything but you
know if all the entries are very close
to each
other then you know by uniformly
sampling s entries uh the additive error
that I get is gamma to the P over2 opt
over root S okay so it depends on how
close these are to each other right
intuitively I don't need many samples if
all the entries are very close to each
other and so if I want additive error
Epsilon
opt then we only need a number of
samples s which is you just plug it in
here gamma to the p over Epsilon squar
rather than one over Epsilon squ which
is what you would need in general you
know gamma was a
constant um and and so um uh you know so
so we we improve yeah so oh one thing I
forgot to say is you know we can
essentially reduce to this flat case by
sensitivity and leis sampling and
chaining okay so these ideas of kind of
flattening the vector that I talked
about earlier uh kind of reduce to this
case now this is just intuition but this
is what's going on like you're looking
at um these Gan processes over
differences of vectors and uh this is
why the error
improves um here is sort of the formal
slightly formal argument for Pb one and
two um if a 1 plus Epsilon approximation
can be obtained by making D Epsilon to
the beta
queries then a 1 plus Epsilon
approximation can be obtained by making
D over EP Epsilon to the 2
Beta over one plus beta queries okay
it's saying that if you had enough
samples to get this uh 1 plus Epsilon
approximation then it meant that uh this
the solution Vector you had is close to
the optimal solution which meant that
you have an improved chaining which
means that uh you know you you could
have used this number of
samples um so you see that if if beta is
two D over Epsilon s is enough to get 1
plus Epsilon approximation but then by
this strong convexity it meant that
actually D over Epsilon to the 4/3 was
enough to get this one plus Epsilon
approximation and if you just repeat
this recurrence you know starting with
beta 1al
2 Beta I + 1 turns out to be 2 Beta I
over 1 plus beta I I mean is that and if
you work it out beta I approach is one
and we actually have an algorithm with
order D over Epsilon queries okay so
that's the idea behind uh this improved
Epsilon dependence and the
same the same kind of iterative argument
works for p greater than two it just the
recurrence works out to something
different D the P over2 Epsilon to the P
minus
one okay so that's the idea how we get
up Epsilon
dependence
um let me just say a few more things
so this Bound for p greater than two
might look somewhat arbitrary but it's
in fact tight and here is a simple lower
bound
instance um
so let's take our Matrix
a uh to have this number of rows
okay um and what it's going to have is
it's going to have D to the P over2
distinct
rows and each row is going to be copied
one over Epsilon to the P minus one
times okay now what are these D to the P
over2 distinct rows think of them as all
random unit vectors independently random
unit
vectors and so morally you should think
that every pair of dot products between
them is at most order one over root D
okay there's a there's a log factor a
root log Factor there
um uh there's actually an explicit
construction that avoids that that log
factor I don't care about log factors
right now um okay so that's your input
Matrix a it's clear D to the p over two
random vectors and then copy each of
those one over Epson the P minus one
time okay
so what is the B Vector the label vector
well in one case it's
zero and the other case is the random
standard unit Vector
EI okay so you know it's one in one
coordinate zero everywhere else if you
want to figure out which of the two
cases you're in you basically have to
read all of B okay so B has the same
size of a is D the p over2 over Epsilon
to the P minus
one why do you need to read all of
B for the error guarantee that we care
about
well if B is zero
then we have to Output x equals z right
we want a relative error
solution right the cost is is actually
zero if B is zero so we should output x
equals
zero but what happens if B equals
EI well if the algorithm output zero it
just pays the norm of B which is
what but there's a better solution
instead what you should do
is you should have your unknown X
vector be the I row of a where I is that
standard unit Vector right it should be
the I row of a times uh um
Epsilon if you do that and work out what
the cost is you'll get that the cost is
actually at most one minus Theta Epsilon
okay you save a little bit by fitting uh
that I entry and the sort of total cost
from all other entries is small enough
that overall you get one minus Theta
Epsilon okay I don't want to do the
calculation but that's the
idea um
questions okay um yeah so I'm almost out
of time I'm going to skip uh the
extension to M estimators but uh let me
just say that for a large class of M
estimators we do solve active regression
with roughly D Squared uh uh queries and
for some uh some MSM like Huber that I
mentioned we optimize it further to get
close to D but not actually
D um one of the key ideas that goes into
this is bounding the sum of
sensitivities for an arbitrary M
estimator and we use a hashing
technique uh to reduce the um uh we use
a hashing technique to argue that what
does hashing Tech technique mean we have
our Matrix a we randomly split it into a
small number of matrices and we compute
L2 leverage scores on that small number
of
matrices and uh these L2 leverage scores
turn out to uh capture the sensitivity
so the I guess I won't get into it but
but the the idea is um to somehow relate
sensitivities to leverage
scores um by by breaking up the Matrix
into random pieces let me just say that
um
okay
so I'll just conclude
then yeah there's a slide here that
shows how to bound the sum of
sensitivities by by roughly D for a
large class of M
estimators so let me conclude so we
study active LP
regression in which we want to minimize
the number of queries to the Target
Vector um we give an algorithm based on
sensitivity sampling with a key idea of
partitioning labels of the B Vector U
you know based if they're large or small
with respect to the corresponding
sensitivity this gives an optimal
dependence on D we also achieve an
optimal dependence on Epsilon by this
iteration
argument and we extend our ideas to
active M estimator regression and bound
the sum of sensitivities for such M
estimators using this hashing argument I
briefly mentioned so that's all
[Applause]
thanks further questions
for so I had a question about like so
the first constant Factor you got where
you didn't even need to look at B that
uh oh yeah that's right yeah right but
how far can you well I mean like you the
the the the scores are just sensitivity
sampling I mean when when you sample by
those scores you read the corresponding
entries at B correct exactly yeah yeah
but like just to like but if I like yeah
so if I don't intuitively but you've
already sample which uh rows of a you
want to keep right so just yeah go ahead
is that how far can you push that like
if I don't want to look at the no but I
don't look at B either for for sampling
for the one plus Epsilon approximation
yeah so I mean I'm just at the end of
the day it's just sampling by the Lis
weights of a yeah I do get the
corresponding entries of B and then I
solve that that small problem
yeah
um but it is a good question how far you
can push that simple triangle inequality
argument you can't get one plus Epsilon
because of the triangle
inequality you think this you think the
improvement from D over Epsilon Square
to Epsilon is is basically refining the
net being
used uh you mean for p between one and
two I mean this this sort of a recursive
argument that you should to yeah I mean
it's it's just in the analysis right
it's like saying that if you had this uh
true but like in some sense chaining
should be tight right uh yeah well I
mean as I said you know it's the way
that we understand the proof of it which
is saying that if you had this one plus
Epsilon approximation then the vectors
are close and then the the chaining
argument gives you a better sample
complexity uh and then you know now you
have a better approximation and so on uh
there might be a way of of doing it more
directly yeah okay I to mention yeah for
p between 1 and two even in the
non-active setting it wasn't known how
to uh compress a regression instance
down to D over Epsilon rows okay so that
that's a result you know that's that's
potentially useful Beyond active uh you
know it was only known how to get D over
Epsilon squar
rows um so so even if you could read the
whole B vector and you wanted to the Lis
weight sampling does not get you D over
Epsilon well Louis weight sampling with
the B Vector adjoined which is the
center thing to do would give you D over
Epsilon
squar and so even you know even if you
could read the whole B Vector we don't
know how to get D over Epsilon in any
other
way thanks
sure weirdly for when p is two magically
comes out of approximate
Matrix yeah when p is two you know
everything is nice yeah when p is two
the Epsilon was already known and it's
like a media for a totally different
reason seemingly which is odd yeah yeah
all right so let
[Applause]
thing